endless pop culture references a very
important line from the Ice Cube voiced
Superfly and hey was that Jackie Chan
here are the Easter eggs you missed in
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant
Mayhem the film's opening gives viewers
an insight into the origins of Superfly
and his creator Baxter Stockman two
characters who many fans assumed would
be one in the same before the movie's
release in other versions of TMNT lore
Baxter ends up becoming a giant fly
after his mad scientist Antics go too
far and he ends up mutating himself with
DNA from a housefly most of Baxter's
incarnations tend to go this route so
it's pretty noteworthy that he stays
Human by the end of mutant Mayhem
although fans don't get to see Baxter
transform into a fly the special
connection that he has to Superfly is
undoubtedly paying homage to their
connection Baxter explains that he never
could connect with other people and was
always closer to the animals he
experimented on which is why he
essentially treats Superfly like a sun
their unique Bond definitely acts as a
nod to their Connection in other
iterations and maybe Baxter will want to
become a new Superfly after hearing
about his beloved son's defeat or maybe
Baxter will leave mutations behind
altogether and create his mechanical
Army of mousers and eventually take on
his more cybernetic form
one of the first villains fans are
introduced to in mutant Mayhem is
Cynthia utram the Shady leader of the
tcri who wants to turn Baxter's mutants
into destructive weapons while she's
more of a minor antagonist and mutant
Mayhem Cynthia shows potential for a
larger role in the franchise one that
could lead to an exploration of her
alien Origins Cynthia's last name utram
actually ties her to the alien species
of the same name these aliens pose as
humans running tcri as a front for their
nefarious Endeavors their small and
resemble grotesque brains that squirm
around and cause a lot of trouble for
the turtles most importantly they're
heavily tied to the appearance of Krang
one of the most well-known and
destructive villains in TMNT this early
appearance from utram and the tcri paves
the way for some big story potential and
the introduction of major villains
Cynthia's role in the film acts as an
elevated Easter egg to a wider threat
that the turtles could face in the
future and bring some of their
Intergalactic foes to Earth
when the group is looking for something
to do in NYC before heading back to the
sewers they decide to catch an outdoor
movie screening in Brooklyn where a bona
fide classic is playing the turtles end
up seeing the John Hughes classic Ferris
Bueller's Day Off while the film playing
in mutant Mayhem is enough to make it a
pretty cool nod to the coming of age
classic it actually plays a meaningful
thematic role for the turtles in some
ways similar to ferris's Buddy Cameron
in the film The Turtles look up to
Ferris and aspire to be as widely
accepted and liked as he is look we're
really sorry Splinter some of the guys
want to see a movie and I try to talk
them out of it
Ferris is like the turtle's personal
superhero for his unabashed Charisma and
ability to be loved by just about
everyone he matches their teenage energy
incredibly well and evokes the spirit of
Adventure the turtles want to have
however the heroes eventually come to
subtly realize that they shouldn't do
things just for acceptance and instead
should follow what they believe just
like Ferris does Ferris doesn't act
simply to be loved it's just who he is
and the turtles become the heroes they
need to be by realizing this Ferris
Bueller ends up being a little more than
just an awesome reference and plays a
subtle role in the turtle's Arc
while the Michael Bay produced movies
are the more recent live-action TMNT
films longtime fans haven't forgotten
the live-action movies from the 90s and
mutant Mayhem has a great reference to
an iconic moment from those films in an
early fight sequence in a garage Mikey
gets slammed into a car while trying to
recover April's scooter as the action
takes place Vanilla Ice's ninja rap a
familiar song for any fan of 1991's
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 2 is
playing in the background hearing the
familiar course will definitely give
longtime fans a bit of a hit of
nostalgia the second you hear the Go
Ninja Go Ninja Go lyrics You're
instantly transported back to that era
of turtlemania it's pretty great to see
mutant Mayhem pay homage to such a
classic moment in pop culture it's a
short gag overall and no one starts
dancing but the quick inclusion of Ninja
rap in mutant Mayhem will surely put a
smile on every Fan's face
if one thing is clear about the turtles
after seeing mutant Mayhem it's that
their huge pop culture nerds throughout
the film they're seen dishing out
different little winks and nods to
popular cartoons movies anime and even
music that audiences will surely
recognize in the scene where the turtles
test their weapons on some watermelons
Donnie mentions that Mikey's head looks
like a mix of Stewie Griffin from Family
Guy and Arnold from Hey Arnold when the
turtles arrive at April School Donnie
loves seeing the drawing of a soldier
from Attack on Titan he's such a fan
apparently that Leo brings it up to help
Donnie realize that they can defeat
Superfly in his giant form by attacking
an exposed weak point on the back of his
neck lastly when the four of them are
captured by Cynthia Dani expresses that
he regrets not being able to see BTS in
concert before everything went wrong the
group tries to sing butter to make him
feel better which doesn't exactly work
the group even mentions liking music by
Adele Drake and Beyonce
uh I think humans seem kind of cool to
be honest Beyonce that guy's the goat
despite them not growing up in the human
world the turtles sure do show a wide
range of Pop Culture knowledge that's
honestly kind of impressive
the new animation style for the turtles
in mutant Mayhem is certainly unique and
boasts a lot of visual inspiration from
Sony's spider-verse films but there's
nothing like being reminded of a classic
at one point in the movie The Turtles
imagine what it would be like to attend
high school alongside human children
this is when we get a callback to the
classic style of the 1987 cartoon this
fantasy sequence isn't an exact copy of
the original cartoon but there are
plenty of aspects that are an homage to
that era first and foremost the fantasy
showcases some hand-drawn imagery also
the colors used for the turtles in this
fantasy are much brighter and more
vibrant those big popping colors are a
staple of the original cartoon and this
fantasy evokes The Vibes of a classic
look for the turtles that fans will love
to see
since Splinter knows that his sons still
yearn to explore and be part of the
human world he attempts to bring the
human world to them by throwing a party
he orders pizza and balloons but what's
a party without some special guests
Splinter has that covered too with some
cardboard stand-ups that result in some
hilariously unexpected cameos Splinter
brings together the Holy Trinity of
celebrities named Chris in Hollywood
with stand-ups of Chris Evans Chris
Pratt and Chris Pine the latter of which
is sporting his Captain Kirk costume
from these Star Trek films Splinter even
tries to do a Chris Pine impression to
impress the boys and highlights his very
defined eyebrows while Splinter's
special guests don't impress the turtles
much audiences will surely love this
small batch of cameos the fact that they
aren't animated makes this moment so
much funnier
in a conversation between the turtles
and Superfly about the mutagen that
turned them all into mutants Superfly
refers to the material as sludge only
for the turtles to quickly correct him
by calling it ooze well we prefer the
term ooze but yeah it's like more like
it's just it's rolls off the tongue
better yeah
it's nice right throughout TMNT history
the chemical or concoction that mutates
the turtles and other mutants has always
been referred to as ooze however back
when Michael Bay was talking about the
turtle's Origins and the live-action
TMNT he said that the turtle's
transformation was more alien based than
ooze-based he caused massive fan
backlash which this interaction is
likely referencing when bae talked about
the turtles in his films having alien
Origins fans were deeply upset since it
went against the story in the comics and
he was essentially ignoring the use
altogether with the turtles quickly
correcting Superfly and his ooze
terminology fans get a moment of
vindication it's pretty great how mutant
Mayhem delivers a clever callback to a
controversial moment in the franchise's
history and the lighthearted feel of the
moment will make it easier for fans to
relive it without too much saltiness
during a climactic sequence in which the
turtles try to take control of the van
carrying the last component to
superfly's mutation machine there's a
particular song that plays that internet
dwellers will certainly recognize before
Mikey Slams on the brakes with Donny's
staff Mondo puts four non-blondes what's
up on the radio so that everyone can
sing along everyone does except for the
turtles while it initially starts as the
original version the song changes after
Mikey forces superfly's allies out of
the car viewers with a good ear and some
Savvy meme knowledge will recognize this
version from the meme of He-Man and
other characters from Masters of the
Universe singing you can almost see the
meme right in the theater and yes you do
get to hear Skeletor hilariously deliver
his anti-praise line while the change in
the song is pretty sudden it does fit
the turtles being modern teens and is a
hilarious nod to a meme version of
another classic cartoon from the 80s
although Superfly is voiced by an actor
with a pretty iconic music career there
aren't any references to NWA or Ice
Cube's music however we do get to hear
Ice Cube pay respects to another iconic
rapper with ice in their name after the
big van Chase comes to a closed Superfly
bursts into the vehicle and speaks an
iconic lyric
this is the opening line to Iced Teas
1987 Banger six in the morning
admittedly it's a little weird when
Superfly says this since it's not
prompted and doesn't connect much to Ice
Cube but for hip-hop fans especially
fans of the 80s ERA this will be a nice
tip of the cap to an all-time great
the film's post-credits scene not only
gives audiences a fun glimpse into what
the turtle's High School lives are like
but it also sets up the appearance of
the next big Baddie to look out for
Shredder it seems like Shredder and his
Foot Clan soldiers are going to be
working alongside Cynthia utram and the
tcri to stop the turtles and enact some
mysterious plan TMNT fans are well aware
of Shredder skills at villainy he's
generally seen as the turtle's main
antagonist so the tease of his
appearance in the next film should be a
surprise to No One still it'll be
interesting to see if Shredder continues
to work with utram and the tcri or if
this will be the jumping off point for
him to become a standalone threat
regardless Shredder's introduction in
the post-credits scene of mutant Mayhem
with his spiky visual design lets fans
know that big things are on the horizon
after nearly losing his sons during a
trip to the surface that goes terribly
wrong Splinter decides that he needs to
train his son so they can defend
themselves his solution is to turn on
some instructional videos on fighting
and put on some martial arts movies
what's funny about this moment is that
splinter is voiced by Jackie Chan one of
the most renowned figures in the world
of martial arts and film Splinter using
martial arts training videos while being
voiced by Chan is a connection that
elevates the entire sequence eagle-eyed
viewers might even spot chance somewhere
in the Montage starring in one of his
classic films
[Music]
what would a comic book movie be without
references to the comic's original
creators mutant Mayhem certainly doesn't
pass up on that opportunity as it finds
fun ways to reference both Kevin Eastman
and Peter Laird the creators of TMNT
when the Turtles first talk with April
on a rooftop a hotel sign in the
background reads the Laird even though
the eye is blacked out this is a very
clever nod to Peter Laird and a silly
sight gag at the same time easterman's
name is also used for a big moment in
mutant Mayhem when April introduces the
turtles to her High School Eastman high
it's good to know that whenever the
turtles go to their new school they'll
always be reminded of one of their
creators
foreign